magic you are in the tire desert of
India we climb down from the dune and he
shows me this well it's a hand-dug well
which is giving water not even three
feet under and there's water there and
there are several such wells peppered
along the dunes this is the desert now
the sand in the desert is a very tiny
part of the desert if you look around
you you see tons of different micro
habitats grasslands rocky deserts all
kinds of habitats replete with flora and
fauna and everywhere you look even on a
dune you see signs of life the desert is
alive this is also the most populated
desert in the world and it's home to
desert nomads who walk their flocks
their sheep and goat through the desert
these are desert Hardy animals and
they're also they also give some of the
choicest lamb and mutton you can find in
India they call it they're walking gold
but it is a land where living is tenuous
how do these people then build in
drought resilience they have a way an
old way right about now if you were to
go into this desert the Sun would be
blazing down a hundred and twenty
Fahrenheit about 50 Celsius but the
people would be hard at work because
they would be tilling their land
prepping for that maybe that one day of
rain that will fall on the catchment
this is what a desert catchment looks
like no trees it's just flat land flat
as a pancake and hard it's slightly
elevated and it slopes down over a
kilometer about one foot over a
kilometer to a basin and these people
are hard at work
collecting thorny acacia bushes and
lining the far end of that basin and
waiting waiting for this come July the
winds are going to whip up the sands and
the sand storms are going to block the
Sun out of the skies and the sand is
going to be thrown against the acacia
bushes and a Bund is going to begin to
build itself and the desert nomads will
wait some more for this maybe that one
day of rain in August which is going to
dump not even four inches of rain on to
the desert this place gets under four
inches of rain the whole year and
sometimes it comes in a single day the
dune is going to drink deeply and hold
the water in its belly like we saw
earlier and the catchment is going to
roll the water down and it's going to
come to rest at the Bund
that was created by these people and
this is going to be a rain fed lake that
will quench the thirst of this community
for the next six to eight months and
then the Sun is going to blaze again and
of course as it must the water will dry
up or be sucked into the land and then
there's a reprieve you see this land has
a layer of gypsum running underneath it
so that it doesn't allow the sweet water
of the rain to mix with the salty saline
aquifers of the desert it keeps it fresh
and they have hand dug wells that pull
in the water as you pull up the water
and so for another eight to ten months
they are covered because they have wells
I was walking through this desert with
Paul Salopek on the out of Eden walk and
we encountered tons of these rainwater
harvesting structures and they sustained
us just like they have sustained
merchants and pastoralists along the
Silk Route for years Paul was it was it
was a 46 Celsius 115 5
and he pulled up some water and he
dumped or doused his head with a little
bit and we had a Shepherd run out of his
heart saying no that's our drinking
water please don't use it for this so
that's how they take care of their water
and they have water security fine that's
what a security what about food this is
another piece of magic the water rolls
down that same catchment and comes to
stop at the Bund I'm standing on a 700
year old Bund 700 year old Bund and
chatter sing my Shepherd friend has
revived an ancient method of desert
agriculture which basically they wait
for this water to seep into the ground
they do not use it they do not defile it
they just wait for the water to seep
into the ground and when it's all gone
the Shepherds become farmers for a day
and they saw their land and then they
wait again and when November comes come
the crops and it's a time of Plenty you
have wintering demoys cranes that come
in you have all kinds of wildlife that
take take shelter in these in these
fields these people have gone from being
beggars to being rupee millionaires
just after resurrecting this ancient
method of desert agriculture so you see
the desert it's food and fodder
it supports wildlife and livelihoods all
within nature but here's the bad news it
had to come right here's the bad news
the Indian government labels deserts as
wastelands not just deserts scrub desert
scrub forests peat bogs wetlands
grasslands they're all called wastelands
to be better utilized and by better
utilized they mean all kinds of things
for the desert they're raising the
desert they're raising the grasslands
they're piping water in from the
Himalayas all the way to the desert the
problem is by the time that water gets
to the desert its putrid
and this part of the desert of chatter
sings that had never seen a mosquito
before now has the highest incidence of
malaria in
Rajasthan the water is what our stinks
with floating carcasses the people
refuse to consume it they prefer to rely
on their own rainwater harvesting this
is the desert that we're losing what's
happening is it's being checkered with
windmills and transmission lines
I walked down this row of windmills 20
windmills and at the base of nine of
them here's what I found
dead Griffin vultures this is also the
home to the great Indian bustard which
is one of the most critically endangered
species which of which there are about
only a hundred and fifty individuals
remaining and in the recent past we've
lost three of them to collisions with
windmills and transmission lines three
that we cannot afford to lose these are
outside protected areas these animals
live outside protected areas these are
not protected areas these are desert
grassland Commons so the government has
been disemboweling the desert it labels
it a wasteland and then it disembowels
it and creates from a living desert a
Dust Bowl I'm going to pause here and
ask you to consider these two words
desert dust ball
desert dust ball a desert is alive a
Dust Bowl is not and yet we when we
refer to a human devastated landscape or
a human created Dust Bowl why do we call
it desert if occation I'd like us to
think about language because language is
what has led to a lot of these policies
when we lay waste to an agricultural a
farm and the and the soil becomes saline
and the wind whips up white sand and
nothing grows there we call it a desert
no it's a Dust Bowl when we call
predators and the herbivores grazed
on a mountainside and the topsoil is
washed away we call it desert if acacia
know that is a Dust Bowl when we bottom
trawl an ocean and make a devoid of all
life that is not an ocean desert
it's a Dust Bowl when governments label
vital ecosystems as wastelands it is a
dire and dangerous mistake but when we
storytellers educators editors
scientists communicators when we confuse
the terms we are perpetuating that
mistake and we are not cutting these
vital and very very maligned ecosystems
any slack if we want the next generation
if we want our kids to understand care
about and act to conserve these vital
ecosystems we need to role model it with
language let us then jettison old tired
inaccurate similes and metaphors like as
barren as a desert or drain the swamp or
big bad wolf or as patricia was saying
yesterday as dumb as a tape here or
jackass
I've walked 600 kilometers with a
jackass and not Paul Salopek I mean a
real jackass and and I know that this is
an intelligent creature hard-working
creature we just malign ecosystems and
animals with language language matters
words are powerful because as we think
so are our words as are our words so is
our intent as our intent so is our
action and as is our action so is our
destiny thank you
Thank You Artie Thank You Artie some
beautiful images there now we all know
that technology plays a big part in all
of this and to kick things off I'd like
to welcome senior director of graphic
visualization lab at National Geographic
Society Steve Brumby
[Applause]
hey there I'm Steve Brumby and what
we've been what we're talking about here
now is data-driven conservation so we've
been and let me okay
so we've been collecting data about
conservation for a very long time and
the issue is how do we know we have
enough data if we have data how do we
know that it's actually being helpful
right how do we actually engage with the
technology communities that create new
sensors the folks who have to assemble
data into useful systems and then the
folks who have to actually communicate
that the results of all that work to
local communities to achieve change okay
when I was on this stage a year ago I
announced that National Geographic was
looking to build a new data platform to
help supply the tools to enable
data-driven conservation and the earth
pass platform that we're actually
announcing right now is the combination
of that last year of work so earth pulse
is a system that's designed to bring
together all of this best data but not
just produce a big vat of data there's
there's a number of systems already that
have large amounts of data we want to
curate that data data that goes from the
bottoms of the oceans to the to space
and beyond we want to bring all that
together and we want to put it to the
use of understanding let's see next one
okay to understand our species the
habitats the impacts that our actions
are having on species and habitats and
the impacts that we're having on
ourselves okay and then to assess the
impact of our responses to those to
those pressures which we do through
protected areas and so we have a system
of information summary dashboards that
are automated and provide a continually
updated view of every protected area in
the world and of all of the you know
species extents and all sorts of stuff
up to countries that can help inform
essentially a dashboard for the planet
right so as we move towards trying to
move the international community to
achieve 30 percent protection of the
world by 2030 we
want to give them the tools to do that
so right now we're going to be joined by
my by a series of very distinguished
panel of folks who are going to help us
talk through these issues of how you
achieve real practical data-driven
conservation so I'm going to be joined
by Katie Croft bill who's an
oceanographer and National Geographic
fellow Naphtali Hoenig director of
research and development at Garamba
National Park in Democratic Republic of
Congo with the African parks Network
also National Geographic fellow Bronwen
egg rios a space entrepreneur and
National Geographic fellow in Africa
Flores Anderson research scientists at
the University of Alabama and National
Geographic Explorer please welcome to
the path
[Applause]
okay thanks for joining us so first
question is to Katie so 95 percent of
the oceans are still essentially
unexplored all right
how do we evolve beyond having very
expensive crewed missions to try at
crude CRE W Edie missions to explore the
rest of the volume and if we explore the
rest of the volume what do we do with
all that data excellent questions so I
think that it's a really exciting time
for oceanography and exploration and
discovery in general because there have
been so many advances being made in
other industries with low cost
electronics and sensors and robotics
think about the supercomputer that it's
in every pocket in this room right now
that has more computing power than every
computer combined that put people on the
moon right so there's so much
possibility in terms of the low-cost
robotics to be able to create a truly
distributed more efficient system than
we've ever had before as you as you
mentioned the big ships the big robots
cost tens of million dollars a year to
operate and they really only look at a
very small fraction of the seafloor very
very well mind you with incredible
detail but we really need to cover a
much much larger area and get a sense of
the lay of the land and then send those
very detailed assets back there but as
you mentioned what what we didn't do
with the data and before I go on there a
couple of projects have been working on
in the the sort of low cost robotics
space one is with the exploration
technology lab the guys in the basement
and that is to use the drop camera as
you can see just sort of a screen here
to work with communities in small island
developing States to be able to explore
their own deep seas so in addition to
the technologies you also need to look
at who is going to be deploying these
these different kinds of assets and
expanding what it means to be an ocean
Explorer so you can't just have a
handful of PhDs oceanographers you also
need to have a much bigger community so
we have this
I'm going on called my deep-sea my
backyard and we also have another if we
can go to the next slide which is
developing underwater LEGO robots which
has been very very fun and we did a
national geographic student expedition
last summer with with these little
vehicles and so we're continuing to
develop them and see what we can do to
really bring these kinds of assets to to
students to to really everyone but then
you get to what do you do with the data
right all right I'll let enough Tolly
okay thank you
so Neftali science and exploration leads
to new senses when you are trying to
protect in areas conservation areas in
very remote and often very troubled
regions of the world what are you
thinking about in addition to the senses
so that you can actually build it into a
system that actually has impacted so
what you're seeing on the screen here is
um is doing some aerial mapping we had
our friends from virtual wonders core
just called skin Chris Milburn come
through a few months ago you can see how
huge Garamba is and and so obviously
it's a it's a very vast remote landscape
on this is just an example here of some
imagery that was taken with those
flights um this is a three so not only
is it fast but it's also a conflict area
we have conflict in neighboring Central
African Republic and South Sudan's this
is a refugee settlement in South Sudan
and just an example here is um I mean
this is this is how we can how we can
conduct change detection over time and
you you could imagine we would want to
do that for refugee settlements or for
illegal mines but here you can see even
a small path if you look closely and you
could imagine also wanting to have
wildlife collars that's a pretty typical
sensor and protected areas and then you
can imagine if you identified paths
using this this imagery that you might
want to place a camera there so then you
have to figure out okay well what are
the what do we need in terms of a camera
or anything to detect poachers and you
have to think of the testing right has
it been tested before it's come out you
can't you can't go to the hardware store
if you're in the
of the DRC so we probably have one maybe
a few hundred kilometers away so not
really ideal you have to think of
timetables so if somebody is designing a
camera for conservation or a product for
conservation we can't just wait forever
for these things to come out you know
the the pace of technological
development is fast so we need people to
who are interested in developing
technology to respect timetables and and
we also have to think about transmission
so how do you get a signal from a sensor
um a lot of these places don't have
mobile phone access they say we have to
think of a satellite solution or a lora
solution or something like that right
and so that brings up
Bronwen who sits out in Silicon Valley
and a lot of the technology not so much
the science sensor but the rest of the
chain that Naphtali just described the
comms and the computing and the power
systems that can work in remote areas a
lot of those are really dual use
technology that industry is developing
and Silicon Valley's at the center of
that type of development where do you
see the big opportunities for
conservation to sort of leverage that
progress that's happening without
getting eaten alive by the scale of the
industrial investments that are being
made yeah for sure
last week impaired reported on a breast
perspective from Hurricane Michael this
category 5 storm that ripped through
Florida last year 100 60 mile-per-hour
winds and they quoted a local mayor
saying had we known sooner that the
storm was going to be so severe everyone
would have left accurate timely
forecasting of hurricane wind speeds can
absolutely change the way we would dress
impact and for the past 50 years it's
really been meteorologists that look at
the imagery look at the clouds and now
make a wind speed forecast every six
hours
so this might sound a little funny but
if you look at every storm every year
every six hours those meteorologists
know a lot and now the world has a
record of all of those storms and in our
current age of AI having a
scientifically validated
dataset that describes Earth's systems
is absolute gold so in addition to a
scientist or meteorologist looking at a
single image
you now have computer vision looking at
an image and thousands of historical
curated validated images that can
provide accurate timely wind speeds so
my my friends at development seed with
NASA did exactly this last year they
built an AI that ran for that detected a
an uptick in wind speeds for Hurricane
Florence from category two to category
three a full day before the National
Hurricane Center advisory came out
that's you know the difference between
limbs falling off of trees and the trees
being completely uprooted right so
they're using the new NOAA set of
satellites called goes that observe the
entire western hemisphere every five
minutes case if we tack on an extra
minute to downlink that data from 35,000
kilometers above the planet run it
through the AI processed the image and
send that four case off for that
forecast off to the API in six minutes
we're now for forecasting storms like
never before so again we just went from
six hours to six minutes that is step
function change okay so after you've
done all this fancy tech and you've
brought in the latest and greatest
commercial off-the-shelf right somebody
still needs to actually use the result
right so Africa you've been out in
Guatemala working with the local
communities helping them understand
toxic algal blooms what do you see is
the biggest challenges to the sort of
capacity-building that's needed at the
community level or the government local
governmental level to help with the
adoption of these technologies so that
they're actually used yeah so government
instability that's the biggest challenge
we have faced and this is Lake atitlán
as you can see one of the most beautiful
places on earth and no BIOS because
from there but it is and we are using
satellite remote sensing to monitor the
algae blooms that have been appearing
since 2009 but with serval which is a
partnership between NASA and USAID we
work with government to build the
capacity to use our observation data for
improved decision-making and we work
with governments because they are the
ones who have the mandate to monitor and
protect their own country resources and
we develop systems and tools that are
very useful and then there is a high
turnover of technical people and
officials
so we had a address this in different
ways one of that is involving academia
more and more so we are empowering the
next generation of professionals that
are going to take those positions and
the other that I think has been the
success of servere is partnering with
local experts so in servire we work in
Africa in Asia and in Latin America we
just are working in the Amazonia right
now and in these regions
Serbia is not a bunch of scientists back
here in NASA but they are local experts
so for example in Eastern so in Africa
we partner with the regional center of
mapping of resources for development who
are from Kenya and from the countries
and in eastern so in Africa and they are
the ones who are providing the
backstopping and working with
governments and even with this high
turnover of government officials we have
a stable science and knowledge and we co
develop it tools together so what are
the real tricks to achieving impactful
data-driven conservation is to open the
links between different folks are on
this table on this panel so Natale what
would you say is the biggest opportunity
that you have to like learn from one of
the others I think that there is a whole
new field now
she with mapping to do it in an
integrated fashion so I think that
bringing in other people's data has
never been easier and sending out your
own data has never been easier so I
think there's a ton of opportunity there
to to share to share more easily it's a
problem there's a lot of wrong about
that yeah yeah definitely
you know I to me I think that one of the
big opportunities to collaborate it
comes from this just like this shared
DNA that I felt the past like couple
days between entrepreneurs and explorers
right everybody in this room is obsessed
with going into the unknown a tech
entrepreneurs have the same thing we're
all looking for the best tools and I
mean I'm working on a program right now
with National Geographic labs and to
bring that got a tighter connection
between the Explorers and the
entrepreneurial investment community in
Silicon Valley that I think will will
help to kind of bridge bridge those gaps
allow for you know a lot of things that
I've totally were just talking about as
well I personally think could learn a
lot from from Africa I'm certainly
guilty of the sort of parachute science
model where you bring a ship in you do a
thing it may be hand some people locally
a hard drive and then you go away and so
that's definitely one of the things that
I would like to work on personally is
how can we bring deep sea science to
more people who have not been engaged in
in it and so I would love to learn more
from Africa about their community
building and and how to engage with
local communities and science yeah and
that that's what we do at Serbia and we
bring the science we are that bridge
between science and an application and
we are working with a lot of scientists
we are scientists ourselves but we also
respect and uh knowledge that there is
wisdom and information that we need like
everything that we generate with
satellite remote sensing needs to be
validated and calibrated we need in situ
observations we need data from the field
and there is a lot of local knowledge
and for me sometimes even funny to see
that there are scientists working in
Colombia
Peru that are using are making a better
use of satellite data that scientists
down here because they are actually
using to taken an action to identify
deforestation so but we are yeah always
open and we like the work together
that's how sir beer has come about
working together a problem what would
you say is the biggest myth about your
piece of this what do you think it's the
biggest thing with the rest of the
conservation community misunderstands
for example about Silicon Valley yeah
you know one of the things that Africa
and I were talking about yesterday is
that she's having trouble acquiring
imagery for one of her programs right
and she can't afford it the license
isn't available and it it really just
brings to light that even for academic
programs or nonprofit programs
especially for commercial programs that
the economics and the business model of
Earth Observation aren't really very
well defined and they're still they're
still very much in flux which I think
has an impact on the community as we've
seen over the past couple days because
there's been so many references to
satellite imagery so I think the the
myth is that maybe space is figured out
right but and I will say for anybody
who's an explorer in the audience that
there are specific programs any Explorer
wants to get some satellite imagery
coming talk to me okay okay state Steve
has it figured out everybody else what's
what's your biggest myth about Naphtali
I mean people give you a sensor and say
hey you must have saved all the animals
by now certainly certainly that's that's
one myth um that is that there that that
you can look at sensors in isolation and
not see not see the fact that you need a
sensor you need a method to transmit
that and that you need a system to
integrate that data and to analyze it
and I think another big myth is that
those systems I mean we built out a
system with with a lot of help from
National Geographic and from ESRI and I
think a big myth there is that you
need some sort of super specialization
and mapping to be able to implement that
in a park when in fact you can actually
with you can actually train capacity
locally and you can sort of have a
specialist pretty easily in each Park
and nowadays the tools that are
available are are easy enough to learn
that that this type of location
intelligence and sort of better more
in-depth analytics as possible in every
Park
well definitely I will think that this
thinking that data and technology itself
is going to solve the biggest
environmental issues that we have today
and we forget about the people that are
at the core of these environmental
issues so integrating that analogy that
I think that scientists had to be humble
enough to recognize that we have to work
together that there is knowledge out
there and that that we need it so for me
that's one of the the biggest meet JD I
think one maybe it's not a myth but
rather maybe a misconception like you
hear all the stats about 95 percent
haven't been explored all this stuff
then you go to Google Earth and then you
see there's the bottom of the ocean
right there and yet the data that's
there is very very low resolution like
you see the big bumps you see the
mid-ocean ridge but you really don't
know what is there and so that's I think
you know when you look at all these
beautiful maps they make you feel like
you know what's there but really there's
so much left to explore yeah I'm
originally from Australia which was teri
incognito for a long time for Westerners
okay so final question in just 30
seconds like lightning around what is
your most optimistic view of where we're
going to be like five years from now
Africa I think it's already happening I
see this room I see the explorers and I
see so much diversity and that brings so
much hope I think that I really want to
applaud Maggio's effort or work to
really be diverse and giving voice to
those that have him
being here for so long I think that we
still need to do more and for example
being indigenous peoples that I say has
been said here at this stage several
times but I see a change that I is about
the first time so and this is very
positive
minds longer than five years but I think
that with a combination of low cost
tools data analytics and communities it
is very possible to have any community
in the world with deep sea waters to be
able to explore and understand their own
resources for themselves I think that in
five years time with the development the
faster-paced development of technology I
think that it's fair to say that animal
tracking so wildlife tracking and other
sensors remote sensing various types of
camera traps I think that's going to
become and the systems that you you
analyze the data within I think it's
going to become much more ubiquitous and
successful and useful over the next five
years right better and worse because you
guys said all the things you know
diversity data analytics ubiquitous use
of technology I'm gonna say hamburgers I
mean everybody I hope everybody in this
room is following the beyond meats IPO
this is I hope that in five years I
started seeing satellite from satellite
imagery and the you know the rebirth of
jungles and that the micro satellites
tracking methane emissions are detecting
you reduction in emissions because of
things like beyond meat like plant-based
meat products that are you know worth
you know ten billion dollars you know on
the market these days so an impossible
burger to import let's thank our
panelists
[Applause]
carefully go alright now to finish up
today I'm looking forward to this last
segment it's about hope five reasons to
hope and I don't need to say much else
than that there are very few people in
the National Geographic family who can
make me more hopeful or or energized
than our host for this last segment
who's a better closer to the day then
Paul Rose come on out Paul expedition
leader for National Geographic Thank You
Santa thanks very much Cheers
thank you well thanks Sam - and this has
been a fantastic day a day that's right
up my street you know it's been billed
as the headline of hope but of course
we've carried with it everything else
that goes with a successful project you
know the ambition and commitment and
technical brilliance and incredible
successes so we've celebrated that today
in a brilliant way this has really been
quite something so now it's off focus
our minds on why we have reasons to hope
we've got five representatives with
their projects not many out of all the
projects we have we've managed to narrow
it down to five so we've got a
conservation educator and there's
nothing more vital at the moment boy do
we need conservation educator we've got
someone from the very front line of that
conflict that exists between wildlife
and humanity we've got the future of
food food security which we all know
it's always been an issue and now it's
become an absolute urgent crisis and we
even got something called ruthless meat
and finless fish which when I say that
sounds a lot like the perfect name for a
rock and roll band I mean if I was
walking past the lucky bar this evening
and it said tonight it's hulis meat and
the finless fish I'd be straight in
there who could resist it but it isn't
two very separate cell based food
products very very exciting business so
we're going to get it going I'm going to
use Carmen Carmen Chavez
she's the tropical biologist National
Geographic Explorer so come on out come
and have fun thank you
thank you Paul I come from a part of the
world that is not only beautiful and
rich as we all know the Amazon
rainforest it's home for many thousands
of plant species animals and everything
else that is waiting to be discovered
also is home to many indigenous cultures
and people and groups but what is a
little bit not understood so well
sometimes is that there's millions of
people that are not originally from this
area and they are settled there in the
case of the Amazon region of Madrid I do
some Peru for example most of the people
have arrived from the Andes
they have immigrated in the search of
opportunities and looking a better
better future for their families some
are there for decades cutting down the
forest and in the most recent years many
are just coming lured by the gold that
are found in their rivers and in the in
the sediments 20 years ago I was very
lucky to go to the man River I was
surrounded by many scientists
environmentalists and researchers that
told me so much about the forest and I
learned to appreciate this place and to
love it and I made my mission in life to
help protect this environment along with
the Amazon center for environmental
education and research an organization
known as the Aesir foundation we have
been working tirelessly to educate the
people that are actually living in this
area already we provide with
opportunities that they can learn to to
appreciate this this area from the
inside out
we meet with hundreds of schoolchildren
and thousands of people in the Amazon in
the Madre de Dios region
I want into the issue - Gloria Carrasco
the woman who is carefully examining
this leaves I was teaching a course in
botany and restoration and she came from
the Andes to the Amazon 25 years before
and she's a dedicated teacher and when
we were working in the in a trail I
pointed out to this tree that it's an
important element and in there in the
area the she'd Inga tree the rubber tree
I didn't know what he meant for Gloria
but she chose just jump out of the trail
run to have this tree and tears were
coming down from her eyes I didn't know
that he had 25 years living in the
Amazon she never had the opportunity to
see this tree she knew about importance
of this species she knew that this is me
she changed the way we live currently in
the modern times now she's teaching her
own students about this place I'm taking
her class to see this very same tree
thanks to the support of the National
Geographic we are reaching even more
people and we believe that we are going
to be able to save this place from the
inside out
thank you
thanks very much common and this is it
conservation education you know this is
give this gives us hope thank you very
much neck is a great pleasure to
introduce Eric Eric Schultz is the vice
president of product and regulation of
Memphis meats and I made the joke about
who Phyllis meet so Eric you're not in a
rock band are you no okay we'll come out
anyway and have some fun thank you thank
you
so Memphis meats makes real animal meat
directly from real animal cells and
process we call cell based meat
production from a single rice grain size
biopsy we can produce an entire cows
worth of meat in the same time it takes
takes to produce a cow roughly two to
three years in a facility the size of a
brewery we expect to produce our meat
using less inputs producing less waste
and producing no antibiotics whatsoever
so I'm going to do a quick straw poll
there so base meat on here and there's
conventional chicken both are raw with a
quick show of hands who thinks the one
on the left-hand side of your screen is
cell based one on the right do you guess
the one on the left you'd be incorrect
the one on the right is cell base
chicken it's a question I get asked the
most what does your product look like
well it looks like real meat because it
is real meat made from the same things
that meat is made from no on the left
unless the inside your screen you have a
the cell base meatball we debuted in
2016 and the world's first cell based
chicken in 2017 and I can personally
test these products are delicious I get
to eat them every day it's the my
favorite part of my job so you might get
ask yourself we want to share them with
the world so how do why do we even
bother producing cell based meat in this
and poultry and seafood in this way well
simply because a Memphis meats we hope
for a world of and not ours too often
progress is pitted as a false choice
against tradition versus innovation past
versus future but if you look at the
history of civilization all innovations
start as an earnest attempt to preserve
our most cherished human traditions and
at the center of that is food and food
innovation and as we move forward to
build ourselves into a sustainable
planet so species and hopefully a
sustainable interplanetary species food
must remain at the center of that
innovation and we're facing an
innovative challenge right now you see
by 2050 the world's population is
expected to hit 10 billion people a
little less than 3 bill
more than today meat demand is expected
to double in that time in order to meet
that demand we're gonna have to produce
and staggeringly large 140 billion
animals and use most of the arable land
to grow the plants to feed the animals
to feed us humanity has an interesting
challenge facing it now on this on the
surface of that it feels like an
us-versus-them choice but it doesn't
have to be you see we don't have to
either choose eating meat or having a
sustainable planet no we can have our
meat and eat it too you see it's gonna
take innovation in all sectors from
conventional animal farming small-scale
sustainable farming and cell based
methods all putting innovation together
to feed a growing world if we're going
to feed billions safe and delicious food
we'll have to work with more creativity
purposeful hope and more technical
discipline and in doing so feeding the
world will allow us to have that safe
and affordable food and do it in a way
that preserves our most cherished human
traditions and allows us to build a safe
and sustainable planet and a Memphis
meats we hope and believe we're building
that world now thank you well thank you
Eric sure yeah this is a revolution you
know feeding us by revolution when you
can't go wrong and if you think about
rock band just get in there it gives me
great pleasure now to introduce lei Li
is lei Li listen field is a
conservationist National Geographic
Explorer and she works at that
incredibly dangerous and challenging
frontline that exists which is the
conflict between humans and Wildlife
come on Lady have fun
[Applause]
meet Lala a magnificent young lion in
northern Tanzania
he's banded together with two of his
brothers to dominate a territory just
outside of Teheran Geary National Park a
land that is also ruled by the Masai
people lalla might not be alive today if
not for the story I'm about to tell you
now Allah means sleep and I often think
of him lying around dreaming of becoming
this beautiful boy
just a wee bit of meaning busy perhaps
but Lala is a wonderful lion and he's
living in an area where there are a lot
of people and we've got to keep him safe
and I remember a day when Lions like
this would roar nightly around our home
in the bush and then I remember a time
when it all went silent and lions were
being killed rapidly for human lion
conflict for killing livestock and as a
result we were losing the lion and it
was an age-old conflict people were
trading in their spears for poison and
guns new age weapons but there was a
sense among the people that something
wasn't right
even among themselves and so we sat
together and we decided under a tree to
innovate together co-creation that's at
the foundation of our work at African
people in wildlife the result was living
while walls environmentally friendly
predator proof cows that were
co-designed with the Masai people they
keep lions safe from livestock and lions
safe from people and livestock safe from
lions and as a result we've been able to
reduce the killing dramatically living
walls are a mighty icon of the power of
community engagement of the importance
of linking traditional knowledge with
modern-day science it's incredibly
important to recognise the strength that
happens when we come together for a
local and balanced solution to the
challenges our planet faces when we have
a living wall we have something that is
with the community it's done together in
partnership and it's been the catalyst
in our work for a model of how we build
community engagement
a global movement for community-driven
conservation where rural people really
are at the helm of the work that's being
done this is Rafael Syria he says that
living walls have transformed his life
from his own calculation he used to lose
25% on most of his livestock to wild
carnivores and his family were exhausted
because they were protecting the
livestock at night they weren't sleeping
the area around their Corral was denuded
as they constantly went out to fortify
the Corral's
and he says that both the physical and
the financial investment that he's made
in living walls has made a huge
difference because now his livestock is
safe and now his family are can rest at
night and the habitat is coming back and
this this powerful innovation that came
working with local communities it
benefits men and I'm very proud to say
also women because the women are often
responsible for fortifying the Crouse
and they say that living walls save them
time and also with the livestock safe
that keeps the the women you know from
being blamed when an animal is killed or
even potentially persecuted so they're
more proud and they have more peace in
their lives so what does this mean this
is a reprieve reliance the roar the
Lions has finally come back to this
landscape we are seeing signs of lion
recovery
this is Lala's brother just recently
seen consorting with this lioness just
only two weeks ago and so very soon the
next generation will be trotting out on
this landscape in a world where true
partnerships and long-term partnerships
with local communities make it possible
to actually find the balance thank you
right
thanks very much lady I can't imagine
you it's the sense of working in such a
challenging conditions seeing it through
that perspective where success is
measured by hearing the roar of the
Lions you can't go wrong now gives me
great pleasure to introduce brian brian
is from finless fish and it's not a rock
band is it Brian just to make sure I'm
not and Brian Morris is the co-founder
and chief scientific officer of Phyllis
foods so come on Brian have some fire
you thank you thank you Paul
fish meat is some of the healthiest
protein a person can consume high
amounts of omega-3 omega-6 whether it's
breakfast lunch or dinner you know it's
going to be a healthy meal but that has
been changing the world's ocean is
getting more and more polluted and
unfortunately these pollutants are
entering the fish fish's body and
affecting our health so mercury
accumulation is something of a
well-known fact but unfortunately
unfortunately this isn't a natural
phenomena essentially I'm sorry this is
because we as a species introduce
mercury into the oceans ecosystem all
those years ago
so we're affecting the health of the
fish as a species we're also affecting
the oceans ecosystem so essentially as
we have more and more of these
pollutants there and taking out tons and
tons of fish from the sea we are
disrupting delicate balance that we see
in the ocean and just to add to this
very very depressing list of things
overfishing is also a social issue
Somali pirates before they were pirates
were actually fishermen international
fishing fleets came into their waters
and took all the fish out of their sea
so with hungry mouths to feed they
resorted to violence now despite all of
this that this the consumption of
seafood is going nowhere but up
essentially we have a flat line on how
seafood we get out of the oceans
ecosystem and that's because we can't
pump out any more efficiency so what
comes into second for the rescue
aquaculture aquaculture does have also
its slew of problems so a lot of the
feed that has introduced for aquaculture
it comes from the ocean so you're not
really circumventing a lot of those
issues as well as the systems of inputs
and outputs it's not really efficient
we're spending resources on feed that
turns into skin bone muscle and blood
and other things wouldn't be amazing if
we could change 100% of this resource
into 100% the product at finless Foods
we do exactly that we take a high
quality fish stock we isolate the cells
that responsible for meat production
mainly muscle fat and connective tissue
and we grow that out in huge huge
quantities and then blend these three
elements together to create a structured
product for people to enjoy a fish filet
I'm very happy to say that we succeeded
in our project we grew fish protein
outside the body of the fish for human
consumption for the first time on
September 8th of 2017 and those cells
were actually part of that project and
what we're doing right now is scaling up
our process so we could change the way
we eat seafood forever thank you
fantastic thanks very much Brian and I
like I spend my life working at sea to
help create large marine protected areas
to save the ocean and Brian's works
going to do that you're probably going
to be a billionaire very soon Brian next
next up is is Caleb from future food
systems and you know we do see a lot in
the press about food security for the
future but only in the last few months
as it become an absolute crisis and we
need to act and what are we going to do
well luckily we've got people like caleb
caleb is director of the open
agriculture initiative MIT Media Lab
and the National Geographic Explorer so
come on Caleb finish it off for us thank
you
you uhyou you proud audience dwellers
hello to the courtyard that's warm I'm
Caleb when I arrived here in 2015 I was
like a super misfit I was a lonely food
explorer and all of my friends that have
become family now we're talking about
all the coolest things like oceans and
they were like oceans are the best
they're like but helical blooms they
suck and I was like I know what causes
algal blooms it's agriculture and
they're like habitat destruction is the
worst we're losing all these animals
we're doing all these projects and I was
like I know what's taking the habit it's
agriculture the answer to almost all the
things that the people care about in
this room has a thread through the basic
human endeavor of Agriculture so if
we're going to talk about these issues
seriously we have to be very much
invested as National Geographic and as
explorers and as a community in the
future of food you just heard about
growing fishings in in lab environments
if this was your first time then you're
like you and crazy and awesome and
you're feeling a lot of emotions
I would say that we're at the beginning
of a new agricultural revolution and I
just want to point that out because
agricultural revolutions radically
change human history they are the
bedrock of why we have to have societies
to begin with we stop chasing each other
around why why we have all the
technologies that we have and so we're
at the beginning of this next one and
it's a it's going to be about the most
boring thing you can imagine it's gonna
be about accounting if you're gonna do
accounting for where things came from
what they're made of you're gonna need a
machine and so people often see what I'm
about to tell you about on my work side
and they always see the apps they're
like oh you can grow this in that place
and over to go farming and it's very
cute they miss the machine underneath so
quickly I'll show you the Machine and
then I'll show you some of the apps that
make it real first step in my process is
called in code I build boxes of all
different sizes and what they're really
doing is turning atoms into bits we've
heard about this before it was called
the Internet it was this cool thing so
taking real things making them digital
so that we can understand them in this
space of the 21st century so that's
encode decode becomes now we have all
this data metabolomic data gas
chromatography data you know image base
data sensor base they do shion's of data
but how do we start to decode it how do
we find advance relationships so this is
where kind of machine learning and
artificial intelligence enters the game
but then the next step because all that
means nothing if the information doesn't
create knowledge so we encode we we
decode and then we recode we have to
work on bringing those things into the
real world so I'm gonna leave the
abstract now and go to the tangible when
I was here in 2015 I had a weird little
box that groats grew plants and I've
been on this journey since because when
I went to school gardens I was
brokenhearted with Michelle Obama's
let's move campaign and all that to find
out that almost every school garden that
opens closes within three years despite
having massive amounts of funding so I
thought a climate in a classroom that's
what we need to build and now I'm happy
to say that we've actually launched a
whole nonprofit that's been putting
these things out into the world maker
kits for gathering data doing coding
doing electronics and doing climate
science and doing plant science it's
called the personal food
I have no time so I'm gonna keep going
fast it's gone around the world I've
held NatGeo hackathons with kids making
their own these are people in Baltimore
I just randomly picked it out of our
community they're there all over the
place the next one so I build bigger
boxes and inside of these bigger boxes I
produce things like medicine all
medicine came from plants then we
synthesized it made okay I won't go off
into that land but let's just say you
can use climate science to decode a
plant's ability to express the
chemistry's that were interested in we
call that flavor it's also called
medicine it's also called nutrition and
so I study how do you do that in these
new advanced environments but more than
that 80% of the world currently relies
on plant-based medicine some of the
medicines I work on are million dollars
a kilo that you can grow in these
containers that can now bring
chemotherapy drugs to a lot of other
places the next thing that I do in my
boxes that's important to tell you I
work on what do I grow in a box that
tells me where to grow in the world how
can I learn by experimenting with
climates of the past present and future
what I should plant in the face of
adaptation and have made this real with
a Ferrero one of my sponsors that makes
kinder and Nutella and a lot of other
things you might like I actually look
for places in the world i climate
prospect them I use their weather data I
reenact those climates inside of boxes
and I grow trees and I see if I was to
bring a tree into that place would it
produce an amazing nut but more
importantly than that how could we
effectively use our climate data so that
we see the world as a catalogue of
opportunity a catalog of climate
stresses that can be planted in it
complaint it within and then say oh but
what would it cost the environment if I
did that what would it create in terms
of human nutrition in terms of positive
benefit and if it doesn't win we don't
go there this is the world that's
starting to come to life
so I'll close with this we put all of
this out open source that's the mission
of my lab at MIT in the mission my
nonprofit when I was here on stage last
I showed this in 2015 to be truthful it
was like half dream half reality I was
like Steve Jobs moment like yeah we're
all over the place made a lot of
promises people don't usually come back
to the stage and like keep promises so
I'm here from that time 2015 to today
these are individuals within our network
in 65 countries across cultural barriers
across language barriers across skill
level barriers all the things that
people told me we're impossible
they were like you'll never get these
crazy weird little machines in the hands
of all these different people and you're
gonna have to build all these huge
organizations and they were all wrong
and so as these people out there makers
hackers students scientists homebodies
doesn't matter come online and they're
looking for that digital interface to
their agricultural future we're building
it thank you thank you very much Katie
so there you go technical genius and
leadership is going to save us all from
starving to death and after a day like
today and these last five presentations
I sort of like to dream just into the
near future and just imagine with you
know what's going on politically at the
moment if every time we came to vote for
somebody on the card or on the screen
it's at the top it said whether or not
that attended National Geographic
explorers first of all that would be
great because will instantly know there
they have their priorities and their
goals and the things that meant
something to them and when it wasn't
there be a big flash up big red card
danger danger this person has not come
and that's the sort of future I see and
we have to reflect now how lucky we are
because we operate within National
Geographic with all the sponsors you
know we've got sponsors of support and
we've got political influence and we've
got money and we've got changemakers and
we can do all that while we do all of
our work but if we imagine that all of
that support was taken away and I know
you're listening so please please don't
take it away
but if it was all taken away we would
still do what we do as nothing can stop
us and the five you just saw from doing
what we do it's in us it's the way we
live our life it's a life well-lived
we just unstoppable we just can't help
ourselves and that's why we do this and
I just like to celebrate that at this
moment thanks very much
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you Paul that
was a great closing that was incredible
so we've thank you to all the speakers
and to all of you listening out there in
the courtyard I know you're enjoying it
we're all coming there so that brings us
to the closure of our day to day for all
the explorers here in the room and for
all of you out in the courtyard there's
a photographic photo opportunity at the
16th Street stairs so if all of you can
assemble there